i'm going to start with i
[ __ ] loved you both in this movie i
apologize for the language but it had to
be said um thank you so much
million questions but i think one of the
highlights of this movie is greg frazier
cinematography it's breathtaking um i
really want to know what it was like
could you talk a little bit about
collaborating with him and maybe was
what shot was really just tough to pull
off i mean greg said to me a lot he was
like it's that the two most difficult
things i guess when he was in film
school they said that by far the hardest
things to light are the uh darth vader
helmet and the bat the batman cowl and i
always had both of them wow and uh
and i think even he i mean he's an
absolute genius master and uh and just
trying to figure out it's so crazy like
you go into it and even in the costume
test and everything you do not realize
how difficult it is to light to light
the cowl like i mean you're just in
shadow like almost no matter what you do
and somehow he managed to kind of figure
out a way through it where it just looks
it looks cool looks like batman but also
you can really you can kind of see
expression and stuff um but
he's he's just so relaxed and seeing
how masterful his work is and it's like
how were you so chill like the whole
time it's kind of crazy yeah that's the
thing is that he really makes it look
easy so it was really it would be hard
for us to know what was the most
difficult because he really just like
looks like he's cruising yeah he's like
morning everyone yeah he's just so
relaxed like you are like i just it's
crazy but he he also just preps you know
very very hard i remember you know after
the camera test that we did or like the
costume test he pulled me aside and he
just said can i just shoot can i just
like shoot some photos of you for a
while and you really wanted to like
study my face and really understand my
angles and
so he just he works really above and
beyond to do what he does
if you guys could go back in time to
before filming began uh what advice
would you give yourself to sort of get
yourself ready to film this movie and
everything that was in front of you
it's very little you can really yeah
that's like
i don't know i think it's so much of it
it's just you have to just be on the day
like
there's so much trial and error i mean
for me anyway
i mean i perhaps for ages i've had like
like nine months of thinking about it
and then day one i
suddenly have to re-evaluate your entire
plan
and uh
yeah i mean it's kind of
and also we kind of you know by even
halfway through the movie i'm just still
figuring out who the character is and
kind of and and constantly having
surprises about how other actors perform
and it kind of you know it felt very
reactive the whole time i don't think
there's enormous money you could do yeah
i don't think so either i think you know
i i you know prepped as much as i could
i was so nervous and cared so much and
i can't even imagine what else i could
have done so
uh i i already got to go i'm just gonna
say that uh i i loved it i really did
and i i really hope you guys get to play
these characters for a while thank you
so much so much cool thank you so much